Last week, I asked about why if you have cancer doing a water fast or perhaps any kind of fastness, that's so good.
I understand that you said fasts greater than 24 hours, increased IGF1 levels and increased IGF1 levels could help cancer grow.
I mentioned this to Dr. Goldheimer, who was the director of true-to-wrote health, as I originally mentioned that I understood water fasting, not to be good for cancer patients, and he was only curious why his response was that IGF1 is reduced while fasting.
That is generally seen as a good thing.
What is his or Dr. Cutters concerned about possible temporary transient reduction in IGF1?
Well, I don't know that his comment is true.
I believe that one of the benefits of doing longer fasts is that you do have an increase in IGF1, and that is the benefit for people, because increase in growth factors as we age does nothing but good things unless you have cancer.
There are numerous studies where I came to the decision of the elevated IGF1.
Now, let me take a step back from that comment a little bit.
There are other good things that happen with a fast.
And I said time and time again that I don't think it's always wise to do greater than a 24 hour fast for a cancer patient, but it's not just because of IGF1 levels increasing.
But it depends on the person. Everybody is different. If you do a greater 24 hour fast, you're definitely going to lose weight.
And if you have weight to lose, well, then if you really feel like to do a greater than 24 hour fast, one day, two day, three day, week fast, we've had people do a 21 day fast.
That seems pretty hard. I've never done anything like that. But if you feel led to do that, then by all means do it, just make sure that you have weight that you can lose.
You don't want to push yourself in a state of cakexia, because that is one of the most difficult things for a cancer patient to get out of is if you're in a state of tumbling weight.
Then you have to resort to not only eating more, but you're eating you have to restore resort to really pushing carbohydrates, because that's the only way you can really get out of cakexia.
So just be careful of that.
I know that there are studies and you you did find this medicine study where IGF1 levels decreased with fasting.
And I know there are studies that will show both things. I do think that there's other benefits of fasting. So at doing a three day faster, five day fast, there's other benefits to them.
That could maybe are a way that any negatives that could go with the cancer patient. So I'm not against doing that. I'm just saying in general, especially if the person is kind of at their weight or below their desired weight, doing a greater 24 or fast, maybe contract indicated.
If they have why I have 30 pounds and I could lose and and well, then it might be a perfect thing for you to do if you feel led to do that, then by all means, do that. So and then I do want to make a point on studies, you know, I am big into study looking at studies.
But boy, it is becoming extremely disconcerting when you're looking at studies because there's so many contraindicative studies out there.
One that says this and another one that says this and it's like, what in the world are these are, why can you have all these studies that are contradicting things.
Matter of fact, somebody sent me a study on glutathione and cancer that in taking glutathione can actually help the survivability of a cancer cell.
So therefore, you should be taking glutathione was a problem with some of these studies like that study of a numerous studies that show that taking glutathione for a cancer patient helps the survivability of a cancer cell are studies that got approved because they were doing it with chemotherapy.
So I would agree that if you're taking glutathione while you're taking chemotherapy, you're going to have a lesser chance of the chemotherapy, a K a an oxidized agent, kill a cancer cell by poisoning it with an oxidized agent.
If you're taking anti oxidants, so understand what glutathione is, glutathione is your main intercellular anti oxidant.
And if you're taking glutathione, you're going to help with oxidizing agents that can damage yourself and understand oxidizing agents are the number one cause of cancer.
If you say my cancer is caused from a toxin in different exposures to toxins, different exposures to heavy metals, what are all those things, they're oxidizing agents, they damage cells.
If they don't kill a cell, well, they can get it a cell and damage the DNA, thereby causing rapid replication.
Evil therapy is a poison, it's an oxidizing agent.
If it doesn't kill a cell, it can actually cause get inside of a cell and cause damage to the DNA and cause cancer.
I'm not saying that chemotherapy is necessarily the wrong thing to do.
I'm just saying that just understand where all this is coming from.
So from a natural perspective, natural doctors over decades have pushed things like anti oxidants, like vitamin C therapy, like glutathione, like curcumin, like nutrition that will help support like alpha loop hair, acid and things like that that will help support oxidative stress.
Superoxid dismutase, things like that that help support the damage of cells from oxidative stress, which is from what's oxidative stress from poisons, toxins, pollutions, chemicals, additives, favorites, calories, heavy metals, toxins in our environment that cause this damage to ourselves that can get inside cells.
And remember anything like this that gets inside the cell that can damage cells that can damage can damage DNA, it can cause me to cause of cancer and can kill cells.
That's what a poison is. If you drink enough poison, you die. Why? Because you have excessive oxidative stress, causing cell lysis and it just destroys the person's liver and the person dies from poison.
So that is just how our bodies work. So taking antioxidants helps protect that.
The other fact is that your body actually makes glutathione, recycles glutathione. That's how that's why glutathione is the number one.
You don't necessarily need to take glutathione, your glutathione is made through a cystine pathway and in glutathione is recycled inside the cell inside all your cells.
So even if you're not taking glutathione, you're still making glutathione, your glutathione is trying to protect your cells.
So long story short, there's lots of studies that will show lots of different things and you've got to kind of take them.
Good to learn things from it and hang on all into citing studies and looking at studies, growing weary though in the last few years because of so much publication bias publication bias is who funded the study.
Well, that's who that's the answer that they're going to get. It's just that's is the way it is. Now, the truth about fasting is their positives and negatives to fasting.
So you got to figure out whether positives outweigh your negatives when you're dealing with it. That's where like any any question you have with anything you're doing, having that relationship with Jesus Christ so you can be asking him and feeling peace about your decision is
is one of the best ways to know which way to go forward.